jaja
[Aplausos]
que no se cambia cuando nadie la gente
flores buena onda
equilibrio teatro hace mucho tiempo aquí
se incluye por la televisión pero es
otra historia
mi nombre es jesús zamora y les quiero
contar una pequeña historia
[Música]
cuando tenía cinco años el protagonista
de mi historia era un niño que vivía en
la avenida larco un hijo único un chico
que pertenecía a la clase media que
vivía con su padre y su madre y con su
abuela algo curioso también por la
naturaleza de hijo único
este chico reparaba mucho en las cosas
observaba cada detalle de lo que sucedía
a su alrededor recuerda claramente por
ejemplo el lapicero con el que sus
padres marcaban su estatura en la pared
del hall
por recuerdo
ser el menor de 21 primos
y tener esto consecuencias buenas como
consecuencias malas y por supuesto
también se dio cuenta rápidamente de que
la casa de sus primos era enorme y tenía
jardín y que lo único que el único
espacio donde él iba así de grande como
la casa de sus primos era su colegio
bueno podía creer
sentía rápidamente que había muchas
diferencias entre su familia materna y
él pero lejos de tomarlo como algo
negativo simplemente vamos a revisar el
asunto y lo valoraban
la vida de este niño era bastante plena
como conté vivía con su abuela y no sólo
vivía con ella sino que compartían el
mismo cuarto algo que era bastante raro
porque la abuela brand señora de 70 años
roncaba todas las noches y no lo dejaba
dormir y además este chico tenía una
especial inquietud por el básquet y
había colocado una nueva gente en su
puerta por lo que todos los días jugaba
vázquez en su propio cuarto una pieza
muy chiquita y evidentemente varias
veces reventó la mesa de noche de su
abuela donde habían algunas estatuas
religiosas y algunas pastillas muy
importantes pero la convivencia un poco
extraña pero digamos que este chico en
los cinco años parecía ser una persona
feliz simplemente se dejaba fluir y no
se cuestionaba demasiado las cosas
la primera vez
que algo lo alteró cuando su padre le
hizo una pregunta de no más de siete
palabras
qué quieres ser cuando seas grande
que responde pues un chico de 5 años a
eso evidentemente no tenía la menor idea
sin embargo este chico y mirando a los
ojos de sus padres
respondió papá cuando sea grande yo
quiero ser pablito ruiz
tal vez muchos de ustedes no sepan quién
es para brito ruiz más millenials son
los más fáciles
primero chico que cantaba qué bonitos
ojos tienes debajo de estas ovejas que
hoy nosotros tienes malagueña salerosa
muy bien el padre cuando su hijo le dijo
que quería ser parto rey después no
estalló de felicidad digamos que el
padre de la vida en la escuela no
asociaba a pablito ruiz como un ejemplo
de masculinidad
y le decía hijo está seguro yo creo que
tú quieres ser cantante pero es como
hobby no no no no yo quiero aceptar esto
ruiz quiero cantar qué bonitos ojos
tienes debajo de estas dos cejas qué
bonitos ojos tiene malagueña salerosa
pero me iría a el padre
sin embargo
el padre de manera tal vez un poquito
más inteligente tal vez un poquito más
manipuladora le digo a su hijo no tú no
quieres ser pablito ruiz tú quieres
cantar pero como joven el niño le decía
así papá entonces qué cosa quiero hacer
y el papá con la sonrisa dibujada en los
labios le decía tú quieres ser abogado
el niño un chico de 5 años y que es
abogado papi que hace un abogado y el
papá con una felicidad descomunal le
decía un abogado defiende las causas
justas
usted puede imaginarse para un niño que
es una causa justa
bueno
evidentemente no tenía idea lo que una
causa justa le preguntaba a papá y por
qué tengo que hacer eso porque si tienes
que ser abogado para que defiendas las
causas justas las causas justas las
causas justas las causas justas
era la devoción del padre porque el hijo
fuera abogado que todos los días le
preguntaba qué quiere ser cuando seas
grande y el niño tenía que ser creía que
responder abogado el papá le preguntaba
para qué para defender las causas justas
y que es una causa justa para un niño de
cinco años si me ayudó con la pantalla
por favor la causa justa para un niño de
cinco años no es otra cosa que un
prensado de papas con mayonesa a veces
todo es de pollo y ocasionalmente alguna
verdura evidentemente un niño de cinco
años note en la cabeza un pensamiento
libertario o la posibilidad de defender
a la gente que más lo necesite no
entonces no entendía por qué tenía que
ser una causa justa y porque tenía que
defender la sitúa realmente se la comía
pero bueno no le hizo demasiado caso y
le respondía el padre de todo lo que el
padre le preguntaba por favor qué pasa
con ser grande y para qué para defender
las cosas justas en fin el padre parecía
ignorar que él mismo lo había obligado
que responde eso y gozaba con cada una
de las respuestas de este niño de cinco
años cuando cumplió seis caminando con
su madre y su padre por la vía del arco
llevaron al cruce de la avenida
benavides allí había una multitud
especialmente de chicas gritando
desesperadas a la puerta de un hotel ese
hotel en el hotel asienta y le estaba
gritando a cinco chicos mexicanos que
habían venido aquí a cantar estos chicos
se llamaban magnetto
carlos alan mauri alexis se les está
y este chico automáticamente se quedó
prendado de la reacción de todo ese mar
de mujeres gritándole a esos cinco
chicos que en su opinión no habían hecho
algo es tan difícil él consideraba los 5
o 6 años que podía cantar y que podía
bailar por ende él quería que todas esas
chicas griten por él
ya se adivinaba una vanidad importante
que este niño no 5 años siga queriendo
que la gente lo aplauda se quedó
prendado mirando y tal fue su golpe de
imaginación que empezó a ver a las
chicas como si tuvieran la cabeza muy
grande muy muy grande dejaron de ser
personas y pasaron a ser cabezas cabezas
que sonreían que mandaban besos que
gritaban que te miraban obviamente el
padre al costado todo lo contrario mirar
a esas chicas como adolescentes
afiebradas fanáticas que cambian de
ídolo en ídolo cada sábado imaginas bien
las cabezas muy chiquitas el niño pero
muy observador a los 6 años rápidamente
se dio cuenta que había una distancia
con su padre el bebé y estas chicas con
la cabeza muy pequeña y él la vida con
la cabeza muy grande
quiero que ustedes vean lo que vio ese
chico por más de que sea imaginación y
quiero que vean lo primero así que para
eso
me voy a ayudar con esta herramienta
les voy a pedir que miren 30 segundos
aquí y que se dejen llevar por lo que yo
digo es muy importante que nos vienen a
la derecha amaya cachete no tampoco
eligieron mira qué tontería tampoco
atenciones
en este momento utilizar este explicar
voy a intentar meterme en sus sentidos a
través de la percepción más claramente a
través del sentido de la vista
miren el centro del espinar y ese se
lleva
imaginen que es un hoyo profundo de
color blanco se junta con el color negro
dando paso a una realidad paralela
cuando cuente 3 les pediré que miren el
centro de mi nariz
en el centro de mi nariz 1
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la cabeza hace
agrando efectivamente eso fue lo que vio
ese niño imagínense ustedes la emoción
de ese pequeño al imaginar esas cabezas
tan grandes gritando por algo que él
consideraba que podría lograr hacer pero
en toda historia está la contraparte así
que ahora quiero que imaginen que son el
padre
esta es de color blanco y el color negro
no se juntan en un hoyo negro al centro
sino que salen se van al exterior y
ahora estamos entrando o yo estamos
saliendo
mi ejército de respirar y cuando yo les
diga me darán la punta de mi nariz
déjense llevar de nuevo quiero intentar
llevarlos a ese momento donde esté el
niño y este padre mira a esta multitud
ahora lo que tenemos en el personaje del
papa cuando cuente 3 miren a la punta de
la nariz
[Aplausos]
eso puede
lo que vio el padre
claramente ya se marcaba por los
opuestos a pesar de niño admiraba con
toda su alma a su padre pensaba de una
manera total y totalmente diferente a él
pero bueno siguieron parando juntos es
parecido con la pregunta que vayas
aconsejarán de abogado las causas justas
la verdad pero el niño le pidió
rápidamente que le compre un casete de
magnetto como ya lo había hecho antes
con pablito ruiz así que tenía su
colección de cáceres y luego de esto le
pidió que le compre una pequeña radio
con un micro donde él pudiera cantar y
bailar
parecía loco pero este niño a los 56
años ya ponía su emoción en acción y
decía si yo quiero ser como él tengo que
hacer lo que las que hacen cantar voy a
empezar a cantar canta canta canta canta
canta de áfrica esos tíos abuelos frente
sus primos y todos le celebraban la
gracia como asturias que el libre chivo
delito enojo de fútbol sino que canta
que raro que lindo lo mira un raro
pero hay mucho no importaba
pasó el tiempo y este niño dejó de ser
un niño y en toda la pubertad pasó con
bastante satisfacción el colegio y por
el momento de la adolescencia y cuál es
el problema de la adolescencia la
palabra misma lo dice
a dobleces este niño evidentemente paso
por una adolescencia en la cual tuvo que
rápidamente elegir quería por el resto
de su vida como hacen muchos a la hora
de marcar en la casilla la carrera que
estudiara
el chico ingresó sin mucha complicación
a una universidad y marcó la carrera de
derecho aunque no tiene idea porque la
estaba marcando más que por la presión
de su padre empezó a estudiar pasó los
estudios generales relativamente bien
pero cuando entró a la facultad se dio
cuenta que el derecho no le motivaba ni
un poquito que le parecía aburrido que
le parecía que la gente ahí lo estaba
buscando justicia sino que estaba
buscando el que estaba buscando el
aplauso pero de otra manera que
utilizaba la verdad
de una manera manipuladora
y no vio mucho trabajo creativo así que
rápidamente se dio cuenta que la vida
parecía ser estudio una carrera que no
te guste para trabajar en una carrera
que no te guste y ganar dinero y la
mitad de tu vida pasártelo así para
luego la otra mitad de tu vida
aprovechar ese dinero y hacer lo que
realmente te gusta
parecía una ecuación triste y clara
bastante simple pero como ya dije
bastante triste dolorosa
se adecuó un poco a esta manera de vivir
estudiando lo que no le gustaba y
empezando a practicar en un estudio de
abogados que tampoco le gustaba porque
entendió que la gente a su alrededor
tampoco parecía disfrutarán mucho lo que
hacían o por lo menos es lo que este
chico percibía
así que dijo bueno como tenga 65 años y
ya tenga plata de haber sido abogado lo
que quiera total tampoco sé qué es lo
que quiero
vivía por la vida así en esta
universidad hasta que de pronto porque
siempre llega ese día en las grandes
historias y ésta lo es conocí a un chico
que vivía de la manera que le daba la
gana era absolutamente feliz
no tenía que ir a oficinas no tenía un
jefe no tenía horarios
yo creo que este chico era hacer magia
vivía bastante bien
y le pareció increíble su estilo de vida
se conocieron y forjaron su amistad en
una cancha de fútbol y muchos de los
presentes deben saber que grandes
amistades se han forjado pateando una
pelota
este chico automáticamente quiso
exprimirle la vida a este otro amigo
mayor que había conocido no podía creer
que vivir haciendo trucos de magia no
podía creer que pudiera pagarse la
comida la casa y también un futuro
mantener yo la familia haciendo lo que
realmente le hacía feliz y no este otro
esquema en el cual había que estudiar a
lo que uno no le gusta hacer para
trabajar el galo cuando no le gusta
hacer para ganar dinero y poder ser
alguien en la vida como más o menos su
padre y las instituciones se lo habían
dicho
este chico aprendió rápidamente ya
siendo un adolescente mejor dicho unos
17 18 años un par de trucos de magia que
le enseñó este miedo y sin darse cuenta
empezó a meterse en un mundo que era
todo un arte descubrió que la magia no
era cortar a personas en dos que no
tenía que ver con animales ni conejos ni
palomas que no eran imanes o sogas sino
que había un arte profundo que podía
hacer que la gente realmente se impacte
que podía causar mucha felicidad las
personas
se hizo muy responsable comentó
desarmado pero claro su padre lo veía
con buenos ojos lo que ya empezaba a ver
en su hijo porque estaba dejando carne
citó no ha preparado estoy jugando póker
ya
al día siguiente papá qué estás haciendo
8 los amigos ya hijo pero está solo
estoy jugando solitario si
constantemente el padre se daba cuenta
que el hijo tenía en todo momento unas
cartas en la mano y evidentemente
imaginaba el futuro es así
como una caricatura de un ago sacando
conejos de una chistera y no viviendo
una vida segura no como hombre de bien
rápidamente este chico se dio cuenta que
su futuro no estaba en ser abogado de
los juicios o en los escritos sino que
estaba en ser mago en ser artista
pero como demonios libere señor su padre
que desde que tenía cinco años le había
dicho que tenía que ser abogado para
defender las cosas justas y que además
le había pagado una carrera carísima en
una universidad muy cara miles de
dólares para decirle papá acabó la
carrera pero quiero ser majo
él se imaginaba la cara de su padre y le
daba miedo
finalmente fue lo que pasó acabó la
carrera se grado sin demasiados méritos
pero sin demasiadas complicaciones
tampoco fue de su padre sacó una cita de
manera muy formal los estudios y le dijo
toma a caster diploma de bachiller en
ciencias políticas cuelga lo en tu pared
porque yo no voy a hacer ahora
la cara el viejo
pero no
el pobre sino que había hecho tú vas a
hacer como hijo único que eres el que
continuo ese estudio de abogados casi
casi era la extensión de sus sueños su
hijo
sin embargo el padre con una sabiduría
que a veces solo tienen los padres le
dijo que antes de molestarme voy a
proponerte un trato
qué es ser vago no te voy a dar una
semana para que vengas aquí a mi estudio
y me hace a mí ya mis abogados el mejor
efecto de magia que puedas hacernos si
lo haces bien yo mismo te apoyaré para
que sean más si lo haces mal agarras
trotter no agarra tu código civil y te
vas directamente a hacer ahora
chico le parecía que es una etapa pero
dijo
mejor este trato medio raro que nada
cerrado se dieron la mano y sellaron el
acuerdo con un apretón de manos pasó el
tiempo y sólo tenía una semana así que
dijo bueno voy a juntarme con mis amigos
más os voy a estudiar voy a tratar de
ver cuál es el efecto que más le puede
sorprender y recordó el primer efecto
que le había hecho este amigo suyo mayor
que él conoció jugando fútbol fue una
cosa simple le eligió elegir sacar un
naipe lo sacó lo miró lo devolvió la
baraja la mente lo adivinó sino que lo
hizo levitar en el aire
para este chico ver ese efecto de una ip
levitando le recuerda la sensación que
sintió hace 15 años cuando vio que las
chicas deliraban por magnetto cuando
veía parque torres en la tele y decía
este chico puede hacer lo que quiera
volvió a sentir esa sensación después de
15 años casi lo que lo motivó a seguir
con la magia entonces le pareció
totalmente coherente que cuando el padre
le pidiera hace un truco de magia bueno
para ver si es que sellamos el pacto
quisiera hacer algo que fuere
estudio con sus amigos e hijos pero una
carta es muy pequeña el que todos
estudios que puedan ser
trabajo toda la semana como el loco
probó algunas cosas
fracasó probó otras volvió a fracasar
intentó el mismo crear algún efecto de
magia no lo pudo hacer se frustró y
cuando ya sólo faltaba un día para
llegar al plazo en el cual tendría que
ir al estudio hacer ese efecto de magia
por fin consiguió hacer el efecto que
necesitaba y el efecto
consistía en lo siguiente
se paró frente a todos los abogados
pero no sacará de bogas
y le dijo
yo estoy a derecho como ustedes pero no
me gusta esta carrera quiero ser malo
y qué hace un mago silva vamos a
sacrificar chambea se esfuerza investiga
curiosea puede lograr hacer que cosas
que parecían imposibles
sean
posibles
el silencio reino
como está arruinando en este momento
y el papá se quedó
calladito de una sola pieza
y cuando el chico dejo la mesa
miro la cara de su padre
y este estaba emocionado hasta las
lágrimas
se paró
le dio un abrazo a su hijo y le dijo
perfecto a partir de ahora serás mao y
yo además nosotros no me pondré a que lo
seas sino que seré tu manager
demasiada emoción al chico se le caían
las lágrimas de emoción y claro al final
pudo lograr que su mayor objetivo que
era que su padre no solo lo aceptara
sino que lo admirar a se había logrado
[Música]
como muchos de ustedes saben o tal vez
han dado cuenta es historia no es la de
un chico esta es mi historia esto me
pasó tal cual y que les quiero decir con
eso que se llama os no que es la
universidad tampoco
les quiero decir que la única manera de
conseguir lo que uno quiere hacer y
poder tal vez si tienes suerte que le
vaya bien en la vida es seguir lo que
tienes adentro en el pecho ese instinto
esa cosa que te dice por aquí no es por
aquí si siempre va a la gente que te
diga no pero puedes ser pintor o no
puede ser médico o no puede ser
ingeniero 50 mil personas me dijeron tú
no puedes ser mago no sé vivir de eso
cómo vas a alimentar a tus hijos cómo
vas a pagar el colegio cómo vas a pagar
la comida ha pasado el tiempo y gracias
a dios puedo pagar el colegio de mi hijo
que ahorita lo tengo que meter a pesar
de que te clavan con la cuota pero bueno
nosotros historia
pero claro esta no es la principal
reflexión de esta historia la principal
reflexión es que si pone la emoción en
acción como la posible cuando tenía
cinco años y les pedía un caso de parto
ruiz o como cuando le puso como tenían
seis y le pedí por favor dame una radio
para cantar no importa que al final no
seas cantante pero algo va a liberar esa
energía en este momento que tal vez 15
años después te sirva de móvil para
perseguir tus sueños han pasado casi 30
años y efectivamente mi papá es mi
manager ahí tenía yo 3 ya tenía bastante
menos incluso condujimos un programa de
radio juntos y además presentaba y
ahorita
pero qué favorito de esto ella para
cerrar
y es que gracias a dios no fui carlitos
ruiz tampoco fue integrante de magnetto
sino que fui y soy jesús salesa mora
diosa y me levanto todos los días de las
mañanas con las mismas ganas de
perseguir mis sueños con las que lo hice
desde el momento en que decidí que iba a
ser artista muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]